foreign
[Music]
people talk glibly about science what is
science
people coming out of a university with a
master's degree or a PhD you take them
into the field and they they literally
don't believe anything and this is a
peer-reviewed paper it's the only thing
they accept and you say to them but
let's observe let's think let's discuss
they don't do it
it's just is it in the peer-reviewed
paper remark
that's their view of science I think
it's pathetic
gone into universities as bright young
people they come out of them brain dead
not even knowing what science means
they think it means peer-reviewed papers
Etc no that's Academia
and if a paper is peer-reviewed it means
everybody thought the same therefore
they approved it an unintended
consequence is that when new knowledge
emerges new scientific insights
they can never ever be peer reviewed
so we're blocking all new advances in
science that are big advances if you
look at the breakthroughs in science
almost always they don't come from the
center of that profession they come from
The Fringe people who see it differently
the finest candle makers in the world
couldn't even think of electric lights
they don't come from within they often
come from outside the brakes
we're going to kill ourselves because of
stupidity
foreign